[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had discussed
a problem involving a nonlinear material
in this lecture we are going to go back
to linear material
but we are going to have
an enhanced discussion going beyond the
purview
or scope of strain energy due to just
bending specifically we are going to
discuss a problem
involving not just bending but also
uh
torsion okay so in preparation for that
and
slightly in a more expanded fashion what
we'll do is uh we'll first
mention uh the strain energy due to
bending which we know
in energy uh or bending
something we already know
and please note that these are these
pertain only to
beams beams or rods for
for axial stretching
what we'll have is
integration 0 to l p square by twice a e
d x and for torsion
the strain energy due to torsion
for that we are going to have
integration 0 to l e square
by twice gj where j
is the polar moment of inertia and here
of course you note that this a is the
cross-sectional area of the beam or rod
under concern
and this g here is the shear modulus
this j is the polar moment of inertia
okay now unlike this formula for
the strain energy due to bending which i
had derived
uh in a previous lecture i am not going
to derive
the this the strain energy to the axial
stretching
or the strain energy due to torsion
i expect that you will be able to do it
in just the same fashion
that we had done it for this case
uh for students enrolled in this course
we can if you try and uh you find some
difficulty we can of course have a
discussion during
one of our live sessions all right now
let us look at an application of this uh
so we considered
we considered a
structure like this
so this is our wall here
and we have a
thin rod extending like this
out of it but it doesn't end here
rather it is in this form
okay so this is a very thin structure
so both these all these parts are very
thin
this length
um so this length
is l1
this length is l2
and we have
this entire structure loaded by a force
which is like this let me read or redraw
that
this is the force p the point force p
acting at this end so
very quickly you note that uh and we
will go into the details of the
calculation
uh if you if you look at this
you will immediately realize that surely
due to this
force applied force p there is going to
be bending induced in this structure
there is no doubt about it we are all
familiar with it
but alongside that we are also going to
have
a torsion applied on this horizontal
part of the structure
okay because you can understand that
this force p
it is going to have this momentum l1 and
that
pl1 will act like a torsion
it'll act like a torsion at this end
over this
structure okay so uh
and you can have more complicated
structures where in addition to this
bending and torsion you may have
stretching also
but in this problem we are not going to
have any stretching involved
okay so let us see how we can address
this problem
okay so uh what we are going to do
is we are going to address this problem
part by part
so let me uh let me name these things
name these different points this is
a this is b this is c so first of all
for the part uh for the part
uh draw it here
so for the part
a b
for the part a b what i'm going to do is
take a cut section at a distance
draw that slightly better
okay let me take a cut section like this
at a distance s1 from this end
so this is s1 and now
if i take the free body diagram of
this
you understand that this has very much a
circular cross section
uh so i have this force p
acting at this end
this is the expose section
as a result of this cut section
and you understand that there is going
to be
a shear force and a bending moment
present here so
let's say this is our our shear force
and uh this is
our bending moment
okay so it is very important that you
have a clear
three-dimensional visualization of this
scenario now what is this m
this m is simply
given by this equation we have seen the
application of
or or how it comes about in in our
previous
discussions
just to clarify
this distance is s1 which acts as the
moment arm
for this force p and this
is uh well in this three dimensional
picture it doesn't make any sense
to to talk about the clockwise and the
counterclockwise sense
but you understand that the sense of the
moment
contributed by this force p about an
axis which passes through this
end will be opposite to the sense of
this
uh this bending moment m which is
represented by this capital m
which is why uh for the moment
ps1 we have this minus sign over here so
now overall this is just m is equal to
ps1 okay
and that's it so for the part a b we do
not have to discuss anything more
because you understand that our our
whole idea is to
take these uh to take the the
cut sections uh over this different
parts
uh and then at the end
to write the entire strain energy
contributed due to the bending due to
the torsion everything together
and finally once we have that or once we
have the expression for that
strain energy we can simply go ahead and
take
uh utilize the castigliano's theorem on
deflections to find out
the the deflection okay so by the way
uh since i have not explicitly mentioned
it uh our objective here
as always is to find out the deflection
at this end a okay so let me perhaps
write that down clearly
so what is the deflection at a that is
our
question that is what we are trying to
answer
okay for these kinds of problems of
course it is
very much possible to extend uh
our ideas from the previous lectures and
to ask
that uh what is the deflection may be at
the point b
or even at the midpoint between b
and c in which case of course we have to
apply
a fictitious force at that point and
then proceed just like as we have done
before of course that will involve
a bit more algebra nevertheless we will
proceed with our question here which is
to find the deflection at a
and next what we're going to do is
discuss what happens
for the part b
okay so for the part bc rather
so what i'll do is
set this question or maybe
here so it is not confusing
with what i am going to write now uh
so for the part
and this is where it gets really
interesting for the part bc what we'll
do is
we'll take a cut section
maybe somewhere here but before that
before that what we'll do is we will uh
since we have said
for the part bc what we'll do is we'll
actually isolate out this part bc
okay but uh so so so when we say that we
will
isolate this part bc what we basically
mean is that we are taking effectively a
cut section at b
okay so so what is that what is the
implication of that
let's see if we indeed consider it like
this if you're if you're removing the
part a b
in our in our thought
then okay so this is the this is the
exposed section as a result of the cut
at b
uh what we are effectively what we
effectively need to do
is uh we have to incorporate
the effect that this force p
uh that what it would have at the point
b
in this diagram otherwise this diagram
what we are drawing
is count is incomplete okay so let me
complete this thing
that's my wall problem about that
okay so basically i have removed the
part a b and now i have to pay a penalty
for
artificially removing that part a b by
having to incorporate
the influence of the force p and what is
the influence of the force speed that is
the big question
first of all you note that uh since i am
removing removing the part a b
what happens to the part a b itself okay
once once i remove that so i'm i'm
considering
these two things in isolation okay
so
is my force
c now to balance this force i must have
a shear force acting
uh on this side okay now
that shear force conventionally i could
i could write
like i have done it here but that if you
write that as v that v
is equal to is going to be equal to
minus p so i'll just
immediately write that thing i'll
directly write that thing
in this fashion that this is my p okay
so if you
understand that if you write it in the
form of a shear force
uh and you direct the shear force in the
in the
other direction that v is going to be
equal to minus
t so it all depends how you choose your
your local coordinate system
so um so like this
s s one is along the a b what is uh in
which direction
uh you are taking the axis are transfers
to this a b
if you take it in this direction then b
is positive along that
then that v is going to be equal to
minus b however if you take the
transverse
direction coordinate axis in this
direction itself then v is of course
going to be equal to p
okay so you understand what is going on
here but very importantly
from the mechanics point of view this is
not the end of it it is not the end of
it because
you understand that there will be a
moment also
okay so uh so that moment
here is going to be equal to uh
pl1 okay so it directly follows follows
from here
we can we can write that
okay now what about this part
okay first of all you note that this
force e that is uh acting in this
direction
it will have a counterpart on this
cross section okay and that will be
directed
in the in the opposite sense it is like
that
this much is easy to understand
next what is the influence of
this p over here it is uh it is again
this this pl but you note that this
sorry pl one but this pl one is not like
a bending moment for this part bc
rather uh it is
just clarify this thing this is the
entire part a b
i'm considering and this is the entire
part bc i'm considering
okay so the pl
one that is going to be applied here
that was going to
be applied in the form of a torsion
and the sense of that was is going to be
um in this in this other way around so
let me just draw that
this is tl1
okay now i've made a big deal of talking
about the sense of these directions in a
rather formal
fashion but even without doing this
uh i mean even intuitively okay although
i strongly advise that you do not
proceed for these mechanics problems
intuitively
but just as as a source of satisfaction
you can note
that this force p it is of course going
to
exert a torsion in this sense if going
uh going in this sense okay so if you're
looking into the part bc
that is in the in the counter clockwise
and so the anti-clockwise which is what
this pl
one is indeed turning out to be uh as we
as we have
just discussed in a different way
okay now uh
our job is only half done here okay as
far as
understanding the the the forces the
torsion and the
the moments are concerned here because
when we were considering the part a b we
had taken a cut section at a distance
s1 from this end and that job is still
not done so we have to take a cut
section
up at a certain distance from b and
consider
that over that little over that portion
which is exposed by the cut
up what is what is going on there okay
so we take a cut section
at a distance s2 so this distance
is s2 from the end b
so that what we are really dealing with
here
is
this part
which i draw in a slightly bigger way
i do have this force maybe i should
okay so i have this force d
which is just this force p i have this
torsion
or this torque acting at this
end b but at this end which is
which is the exposed surface due to this
cut section here
uh so this distance again mind you is s2
at that end what i will have
is a bending moment acting
in this plane okay so suppose
if i were to write
my
my x-axis in this fashion
my
my y-axis in this fashion
my z-axis in this fashion
then or this or this bending moment
which i have just drawn
that bending moment is actually lying in
the plane
x z i repeat this bending moment is
lying in the plane
xz and please note that this torsion
its sense is along the x direction okay
so if you curl your finger
along this arrow then your thumb
would be pointing in the positive x
direction
okay and this one that is
so if you curl your finger again along
this
along this arrow then your thumb would
be pointing in the
negative y direction okay so
actually this is much easier to discuss
uh
in a face-to-face discussion uh
but i hope i hope the i really hope
it will be clear okay so because i have
just mentioned the direction
in which your thumb should be pointing
so again i repeat if you curl your
finger along this
uh this arrow your thumb would be
pointing in the negative
y direction all right now
uh let us let us write down the
the equation for the bending moment so
for this m
okay now this m
will be m minus ps2
equal to zero so this is just m equal to
ps2 and t the torque
simply pl1 okay so for the part a b
we have no contribution from the torsion
we have only the contribution from the
bending
which is m at at the generate distance s
one it is m equal to p
s one and for the part b c
at the generate distance s two from the
part b now from the end
uh from this point b we have m equal to
p s two
and we have t equal to pl one okay you
note that
uh i mean there would be a compensating
uh
torsion at this and it is it is that we
have what we are talking about
okay so uh
plus you you also note that i mean this
this diagram is far from complete
uh you would have very much a
shear force in that direction if you if
you
draw that
you draw that shear force that v
is going to be equal to minus p and
you can actually draw a compensating
torsion here but i i will just refrain
from doing that
because it's going it is it has already
cluttered up the picture over here
okay so maybe over here
okay so this is our t so that is this d
uh we have the v also this v is going to
be equal to minus p but we
don't need it anyway um
on that note i mean you could have
strain energy associated with shear but
here
uh but usually that contribution is very
very small we are not going to get into
that discussion
uh but it is possible to have uh
the strain energy associated with shear
also but in all these problems we are
neglecting that contribution
okay uh so now it is time to
account for um for these these different
parts
all together in the expression of strain
energy and that's exactly what we're
going to do
in the next page
so for our total strain energy
we have from 0 to l1 so this is
0 to l1 corresponds to the part a b
here we have the contribution solely due
to bending
which is why we write the strain energy
associated with bending
for the part bc
we have to carry out the integration
from 0 to l by
l2 and there we have the contribution
from the bending which is again m square
by twice e i
plus we have the contribution from the
torsion
which is t squared by twice gj
this entire thing
i've made a mistake here this
integration is actually
with respect to ds one
okay with respect to the s1 variable
and just to make things very clear
this is uh for a b
and this is
for bc okay
so now if you carry out if you try to
find out
the deflection at the point a all that
you have to do
is carry out this differentiation
of the total strain energy u with
respect to the force p
which is applied at the point a and
what you are going to end up with so let
me just write one intermediate step
so this is just as before m by e i
del m l p
d s 1 plus
integration 0 to l 2
m by e i
del m l t d s 2
plus integration 0 to l by
l 2 e by g j
l t lp
es2 and i'm not going to go through the
intermediate algebra
you can all do that so the ultimate
answer that i will obtain
is pl1 cube
cei plus
please note that i am not doing some
trick here to
now to try directly obtain the formula i
have actually skipped some steps
i have the answer written down on a
piece of paper near me
i'm just looking at it and writing down
the answer
so there is no magic involved you
actually have to do the
intermediate steps to get to this answer
okay so that's it uh let me just check
yeah that seems correct
right okay
so you can have as i mentioned you can
have more complicated structures
you could have variations on this
problem where maybe you are asked to
find out the deflection
at some other point in which case you
have to apply a fictitious force there
carry out this kind of a differentiation
and ultimately set
that fictitious force value to be equal
to zero so you can you can have very
different
even different kinds of interesting
variations
on this kind of problem all right so on
that note i'll end this
video lecture thank you